when I was a kid I used to love watching
the prices right because they had the
rotating games and you know you always
surprised what game they were gonna
bring back and how they bring them back
Plinko today or is but you know so we
have different segments that we work in
from time to time it always makes me
think of Bob Barker and the price is
right so what's more likely as today's
game okay
we need like theme music well it's more
likely do I punch you twice before the
show's over or three times
punch me once and we're doing your
podcast you know we'll be scheduling it
for you it was supposed to be tomorrow
but apparently you've changed your
schedule and now we got to do it today
he's got a problem for you it was but it
doesn't seem to matter nobody cares
about my life are you done now I'm done
all right what's more likely you get
fired or I get fired
Joe Flacco holds off drew lock all year
or Eli Manning holds off Daniel Jones
all year oh man this is a good one I
think if you have to make me choose
there though I'm going to say that Joe
Flacco holds off drew lock just because
I'm gonna say one drew lock may be a
little bit more raw - drew lock is also
okay a second-round pick Daniel Jones is
the sixth pick of the draft and I think
there will be more of a public clamoring
for him when all said and done I think
Denver has a chance to be a little bit
better football team - I'm going with
the Broncos as well because of the
phrase holds off because I think there's
a good likelihood Joe Flacco gets
injured that's not holding him off yeah
that's just getting injured and blocked
comes in and takes it from him but I we
talked about this last week and I've
been meaning to write something about
this at PFT I just continue to believe
that that this is moving toward Daniel
Jones being the week 1 starter the clue
is staring us right in the face they
made him the sixth overall pick in the
draft yeah they like this guy right he's
their guy right yeah hello sixth overall
pick not 17 yes not 30 not 22 6 yeah and
I I just I think you're wrong but if
you're right I'm gonna call you the man
or a Hobson they'll call you King Gloria
Gloria anyway yeah yeah something
next one what's more likely
Washington quarterback Dwayne Haskins
doesn't win the starting job or Josh
Rosen the new Dolphins quarterback
doesn't win the store well this one's
easy Dwayne Haskins I'm gonna say is
more likely here that doesn't win the
starting job I fully expect Josh Rosen
we talked about it and start the show I
expect him to beat out a Ryan
Fitzpatrick who's much farther along in
his career and not as talented as Case
Keenum Dwayne Haskins one-year college
football you know Case Keenum has got
experience and yeah I think case
Kingdom's got more talent than than a
guy like Ryan Fitzpatrick I think he can
hold off a Dwayne Haskins longer or at
least have a substantial amount of time
in the lineup you should you have to
factor in though yeah you have to factor
in that the Washington Organization
riking the decision oh I know you know
yes that you know it's close Daniel
Snyder might just be like I want him out
there maybe maybe maybe not even if it's
close yeah maybe if it's clear that
Keenum is a guy in the locker room is
firmly behind Keenum the one city where
that may not matter is Washington yeah
right where you know what Haskins is our
guy I don't care put Haskins out there I
don't want Kenan to start winning games
and looking good and then we have to
delay Haskins I think God forbid we have
to keep Kenan for another year right get
Haskins out there we're gonna take our
lumps big we're gonna keep loading up
the team we're gonna move forward so I
still agree with you yeah but you can't
rule out the possibility that Washington
will screw it all up and defy common
sense and go with Haskins instead of key
yeah I agree with you you can never
worry about you I mean you always got to
worry about the owner you know
overarching everything and just going
okay no you're the man and I said so and
play them all right this one I'm gonna
revise slight okay cuz I think as it's
written it's a no brainer what's more
likely Cuyler Murray makes multiple pro
bowls or Cuyler Murray gives up on
football and goes and plays baseball I'm
gonna say multiple Pro Bowls I think
that I think Cuyler Murray loves hope
all too much he's not going to play
baseball
he loves it for now I guess we'll see
what happens if right he takes a huge
hit Pat White the former West Virginia
quarterback
one hit for Mike Taylor and he was done
right with the NFL right and you know
what what if you just you know there's a
ceiling for everyone between what you
accomplished at college football and the
Pro Football Hall of Fame and you bump
that ceiling at some point during your
professional career Yeah right you're
familiar with that ceiling
I mean where's calimary ceiling we don't
know just because he was great plenty of
Heisman Trophy winners have not been
great NFL players yeah we don't know
that he's gonna be great we assume he's
gonna be we talked about how far he
would have fallen for him and the number
one overall pick he may have made it all
the way to 15 oh yeah we don't know your
so I don't know how good he's gonna be
and if football is difficult for him
right if it hurts right at his feet are
already hurting after a minicam practice
yeah if he decides that this just isn't
as easy as I thought it was gonna be
that Oklahoma is a hell of a lot easier
than Arizona yeah we've already seen him
pay back multiple millions of dollars to
a baseball team to go play football at
some point down the line and he has the
right to do this under his contract he
can pay back the unearned bonus money
and go play baseball and after three
years you'd only have to pay back like
five million or so I mean it's only five
million but if Florio but if they keep
coming after him they keep coming after
him and and he just and he gets to a
point where it's like man this is hard
and this is difficult and this isn't
anything I thought it was gonna be and
god baseball's got to be easier than
this I mean we can't rule that out
I'm not saying it's a high probability
but we can't rule it out no I mean
you're right I mean he always has that
avenue to go there I just you know again
I'm just gonna look go back from what I
saw evaluating the player the fact that
everywhere he's gone he stood out and
been an elite football player whether
that's not what we're losing a game in
high school barely losing in college you
know hey there question mark certainly
about the player yeah the size and can
he be durable throughout the year and
and play 15 16 17 weeks in a row we're
gonna find out but for right now I am
gonna bet on him because he's given me
nothing else so far to show that there's
anything negative so I might go with it
look I don't dispute that I hope he
turns out to be a star player and I hope
he does make multiple Pro Bowls but we
have to at least keep an eye on the
possibility because there have been
quarterbacks we thought were gonna be
great that weren't right it's happened
it's not unprecedented and you know you
mentioned that he's got this stellar
record as a starter King made this point
a few weeks ago people lost their minds
that we haven't seen him tested by true
adversity oh oh so it's a knock against
him that he won too many games no the
reality though is if it comes easy for
you and all of a sudden it's not easy
anymore how does that affect your
enjoyment we tend to like the things
we're good at sure right
if all of a sudden we don't feel like
we're as good at something as we were
maybe we don't like it as much as we
could and unlike 99.9% of the pro
football players out there he's got a
viable alternative in professional
sports and and if there's you know
whether it's the A's or whoever may
acquires rights in the future if they
keep coming after him if they do it just
right if they press the right button at
the right time you never know what he's
gonna that's all I look until we know
that this guy is a Pro Bowl caliber
talent we just won't know so all right
we're gonna take a break when we return
we're gonna take a look at the Colts
offseason today to team the Peter King
had at number three yeah in his power
rankings and that's one of the few I
actually don't disagree with more PST
live right after this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports